if there is one easy delicious Japanese
dish that you should make it's cute on
baby another cooking video another day
you know cooking is an interesting I'm
not wearing any [ __ ] pants
so today we're gonna cook a simple
Japanese dish that I believe anybody can
make and I really want you guys to try
to make this one because it's just it's
so [ __ ] easy now if you've ever been
a Yoshino you guys probably had one of
their beef bowls well instead of going
to the ocean or eating that and getting
diarrhea for weeks you guys should make
your own beef bowls but today we're
gonna put a different spin on the beef
bowl because we're not actually using
beef we're using a protein of my
personal choice pork baby well did you
guys know high ed uh okay that is not
that funny man now on to my favorite
part of this video let's talk about
ingredients bay bay now before we go
ahead and talk about specific individual
ingredients there is a component to this
dish that has to be made beforehand and
that is the dashi stock now if you can't
make the dashi stock with the
ingredients that I have you can simply
just get a dashi powder you take hot
water you throw the dashi flakes in
there and then you have instant dashi
broth bing-bang-boom but the Dutch
brought that I'm going to make if you
have an Asian supermarket around you
consists of a few components number one
is dried shrimp I love the taste of dry
shrimp in my dashi broth because it
brings this really really intense
seafood flavor
the next dried seafood that I put in is
typically what we see in a lot of Korean
dashi which is dried anchovies if you
look at the dried anchovy it comes whole
what you're actually going to do is
pinch the head take it off and remove
the innards because that actually adds a
bitter flavor to your broth and you
don't want that you just want the body
and of course the most common ingredient
in dashi broth is the Katsuobushi flakes
cut to a bushy is the dried and cured
bonito fish what you'll see it come in
is this big plastic bag and when you
take it out it'll look like pencil
shavings and they'll smell like fish
food honestly and of course no dashi
would be a dashi without a large dried
piece of kelp or seaweed or kombu as
they call it in Japanese this
is going to add that umami into your
broth and honestly when you cook this
dashi broth it's gonna smell like the
ocean and that's what you want
now but moving on from the dashi broth
in order to make the sauce for this
you're gonna take that dashi broth and
you're going to add good all the regular
Kikkoman soy sauce the brand of choice
for most people at home and in fact I
once tried to get a brand deal from
these people but they said what the [ __ ]
do we need your ugly face for and of
course we have aji meeting which is a
sweet cooking rice seasoning it is sweet
and there is a decent amount of alcohol
in here so typically with this dish you
especially you don't you see people you
suck it and they'll simmer it out I
don't actually think the sake is that
important you just need a G meeting and
then you need to reduce the amount of
sugar that you put in the broth later
and I think it tastes perfectly fine in
this dish I actually like to use raw
sugar
III don't know why I think it's because
the granulated sugar the white sugar
that we usually use is a little too
sweet you know and plus why's everything
gotta be white she a control have a
little Coolio sugar all right a little
knob of ginger won't hurt IVA the
vegetal components is going to be the
yellow onion the reason why simply
because it's cheap as [ __ ] and it's
quite abundant and for garnish we'll be
using these spring onions or green
onions it also adds a nice crunchy
little texture at the end of it with all
that fatty delicious pork that we're
gonna be having but David jus daun means
beef because Q is beef shut the [ __ ] up
I already know that we're calling this
boot Padang boot eyes pork [ __ ]
specifically is going to be thinly
sliced pork shoulder very very cheap cut
of meat but because the Berkshire pork
and it has such amazing marbling and the
fat and a Berkshire pork is oh well now
that we talked about the ingredients
let's move on and let me shut the hell
up and let's get to cooking baby
oh I forgot we're also going to sue via
neg to put on top son of a [ __ ]
oh and then some togarashi spiced [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] cares first things first
let's make a dashi broth you are going
to get a pot of cold water roughly about
six cups and add a half sheet of dashi
kombu to it while that's going take
about six and Chevys and four
tablespoons of the dried shrimp and put
it inside a t-ball infuser or if you
don't have that use cheesecloth or throw
them straight in the water and take them
out when you're done with it after about
10 to 15 minutes of simmering on a
medium boil take out the kombu it's done
its job it's good to go it'll be twice
as big after hydrated so you know I'm
saying ah ha ha now leave the dry
seafood in the water for another 10
minutes to do its job in the meantime
prep your veggies chop up some green
onions and slice up your onions as well
most people slice them up the other way
personally I don't think it makes a damn
difference so whichever way it's fine
just not too thin or thick ten minutes
that pass now remove your Google home
pod out the water and we are going to
put in two big handfuls of Katsuobushi
shavings you don't really need to simmer
this for too long just a minute and let
it sit in the hot broth for about five
minutes and you're good
strain and press the cut so boshi
shavings like the [ __ ] owes you money
to get all the goodness out of them next
up is the protein we are going to add
the thinly shaved pork shoulder slices
to a cold pan first because we want the
browning but we also want to render out
the fat don't worry when the pan gets
hot you'll get a nice sear steer the bad
boys and when you're done and all that
fat is rendered out leave it in the pan
for the onions add your onions to the
pork fat on high heat and slightly
caramelize them with the fat some burnt
charred pieces are going to be fine
because we actually want that after
about a minute remove it because we
don't want to cook it for too long
because it's gonna do the rest of his
job in the broth now it's time to marry
everything together add a couple of
ladles of your broth to the hot pan and
then add two tablespoons or so of soy
sauce 1 tablespoon of sugar of your
choice I actually like using brown sugar
but I only had Roscher to the left so I
used that I forgot to record the meeting
but you'll use about 2 tablespoons of
that as well
is a tablespoon of chopped ginger and
mix it up a bit
now all that's left to do in terms of
cooking is to add your ingredients back
into the pan so this is where you really
get to have fun and make it taste like
the way you want it what I'm giving you
right now is a basic foundation of how I
personally like it to taste if you want
it more salty add a little more soy
sauce
if the broth is too thick thin and out
with a little bit of more dashi and you
kind of adjust as you go you're going to
eat this this [ __ ] is gonna go in your
mouth and out your ass so make it the
way that you want it to taste as a pro
tip I didn't really do this if you want
the meat to be a lot more tender you're
gonna cover this up and let it simmer
for another 15 or 20 minutes and then
add the onions at the last two minutes
finally we are at the assembly part you
are going to take all that protein broth
and onions and dump it over a bowl of
steaming white rice garnish it with the
little green onions for that texture and
that crunch and that freshness then
you're gonna take that wonderful
sous-vide egg that I made beforehand
place that in the middle add a little
beni shoga or pickled red ginger because
we're gonna need that to break up all
that fat and there you have it here is
my recipe for the bouton and I guarantee
you once you put it in your mouth it's
going to be this is going really weird
it's gonna be delicious
my favorite part of these videos the
eating time baby look at the jiggle in
that wonderful sous vide egg oh yeah you
like to eat there it is people right
there that beautiful boot cut on right
there green onions the beni shoga di
pickled ginger the sous vide egg and
those caramelized onions and that
delicious delicious broth oh that's a
sous-vide egg right there it's like
jammy it's not it's not like super yogi
like when you have a poached egg it's a
little it's jam like look at that Oh
someone talked about comfort food in a
bowl that pork fat just melted into that
delicious rich soy and sugar based sauce
the pickled ginger just breaks
everything up and you have a little
texture and crunch from those green
onions I mean let me just get a spoon I
think it's full hmm I'm telling you guys
it is that khuda buta pork fat that just
makes this dish if you had the the broth
and you tasted it without putting the
onions in the pork in there it doesn't
taste that great it just tastes like
what it is which is just sugar soy sauce
and the IG meeting but when you add that
pork fat to it it just takes it to
another level fat equals flavor people
who is its comfort in a bowl there's a
lot of dishes that you'll eat and that
you'll create and to be honest with you
the dishes that I typically would go for
are the ones that are very homey I'm not
looking for fancy steaks or whatever but
this might actually be one of those
dishes that I want it's just I mean come
on
oh man and if you're a little bit iffy
about you know stuff that has like a
really really harsh porky flavor you
don't have to worry about that the
ginger kind of covers that up and on top
of that that soy gets gets married into
that pork fat and the poor fat gets
mingled in with the soy and it's just
it's heaven in a ball I don't know what
else I'm gonna make I think I'm gonna go
for a Korean dish
I might actually make you guys this at
this dish called Melancon which is like
a seafood Korean stew and it's getting a
little warmer so I want to make that
before it gets too hot but yeah I'll see
you all next time my foot is bleeding
right now through the sock this will
make me feel better love you